hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions on my
Jaime Lannister video yesterday I named
this video Jaime vs. Cersei just because
that's what a lot of the questions were
talking about even if that's not the
narrative that the show decides to back
I at least want to see them address it
just because a character's that's
supposed to have some common sense can
only go so long before they turn to the
people they love and say you're crazy
you can't do this anymore so just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far as we
get into questions here we go first
question
Sonny asks what do you think would
happen if White Walkers came across
stone men with great greyscale I would
say that White Walkers probably wouldn't
be affected they're probably immune to
most human diseases there isn't a
precedent for that so that's just
speculation but it seems like most of
the things capable of affecting White
Walkers are magic things associated with
the red God and Dragons which all might
end up getting lumped into the same
category depending on how the show and
George are Martin decides to explain the
red god if there's anything that I'm
going to be disappointed with when Game
of Thrones is completed as run it's that
because it has such a short time to
explain things with 10 episodes there'll
be a lot that it won't talk about so if
we get any kind of like deep exploration
of the red God it'll probably happen in
the books
next question yang's asks do you think
that Myrcella is dead and in case she's
not do you think it's possible that
Duran Martel would try to make her Queen
in order to make trystane King no I
don't think that the show is going to go
in like the book direction with a lot of
this door and stuff so it seems like
Marcela's dead in the actress herself
the actors the Placer also thinks that
she's dead they're being so tight-lipped
about what's going on with season six
they they haven't announced who's in the
cast but it seems like Myrcella is going
to be dead I hope they stick with it
because what I'm hoping to see from
Jaime's character is him lose all the
people around him like being unable to
save the people that he loves and then
being presented with this Cersei
situation and seeing how he deals with
it like he wants to save the people he
loves but what do you do and the only
person that you love is completely
batshit crazy they could also go in the
direction where they have him cut ties
with Cersei and tried to save Tommen be
like all right everything has gone to
[ __ ] in my life my family is crazy but
I'm gonna save this kid here he seems
like he could grow up to be a good
person so Jaime might end up cutting as
losses and just trying to rally behind
Tommen next question
Christian asks what will happen to aria
now that she's blind will she be going
through some kind of training or is the
blindness just a punishment well I mean
they'll explain that in the first couple
of episodes I think it was episode 2
before we saw Aria this year logically
you think the show would have a little
bit of fun with that so hopefully like
it you know in the first episode or so
we get to see her try to figure out how
to deal with being blind
whenever jaqen wasn't sending her on
missions this year she spent most of her
time preparing bodies which is actually
something that you could probably do
pretty well blind but you don't have to
move around you could memorize the
locations of all like the embalming
fluids and all the all the things they
used to treat bodies but it'd be a huge
mistake for the show not not to give us
a couple scenes with Aria just like
fumbling around the wharfs blind at
night so yes gonna have some fun with
the blind stuff she'll probably gain
back her sight at some point during the
season but only once she learns more
about the magic of the faceless men like
the techniques that they use that
journey from sightless to sight will
just just be a deeper exploration of the
faceless men it's all the same to the
many-faced God
next question Caden s who would you
rather fight to the death the mountain
or the smiling Knight well the way they
talk about the smiling Knight he sounds
more like a ramsey type character so I
wouldn't want to lose a fight to him so
I would say the mountain the mountain
would probably like squish my skull and
I would die instantly so that would be a
pretty quick death the smiling Knight
sounds like someone who would just like
play with me and just let me die over
the course of like four or five days so
that would be way worse next question
bihaan asks do you feel like there's
going to be an even bigger focus on the
twins next season so when I sell you a
question I actually I took to meetings
the twins isn't in terms of the location
like where the phrase live and the twins
is in Jamie and Cersei so I'll start
with the Jaime and Cersei stuff first it
seems like what's happening is is
Jamie's gonna go back to King's Landing
and most of Jamie's story will revolve
around what's going on with Cersei
Cersei is involved in this larger
conflict Jaime's not really a part of
that so I think when the episodes do go
to King's Landing we will see more Jaime
and Cersei trying to figure out what to
do about the faith militant in Cersei
situation it's kind of like a repeat of
Jaime and Tyrion in season 4 when Tyrion
was stuck in the black cells waiting for
trial
circe is still going on trial with the
faith that hasn't happened yet that's
gonna be a season six thing in terms of
the twins the location like in terms of
the phrase no I don't think that we'll
see them again just because Walder Frey
the infamous Walder Frey was cast on
another show he's on the strain right
now so he probably isn't that time to do
Game of Thrones stuff next question Omar
asks why didn't Jamie or Tywin sit on
the Iron Throne after the mad Kings
death well it wasn't so much like you
know first come first serve like I mean
just because the chairs empty doesn't
mean anybody can sit in it the Lords of
the kingdom had to support the successor
and everyone just agreed Robert was the
best choice even though there were a
couple candidates during season one of
the show Robert is remembering old
battles with Barristan Selmy he talks
about going up against randyll Tarly
and how randyll Tarly if he wanted to
could have won the war and sat on the
Iron Throne himself as we know things
couldn't go down that way Robert ended
up being king but the way the books in
the show presented it was kind of like
the wrong choice like Robert should have
never been King he just he wasn't meant
to rule I think we could all probably
agree that nobody took Jamie seriously
enough to think him a serious candidate
and all the other Lords of Westeros
probably didn't want to see Tywin get
that much power so I think one of the
bigger reasons you know I mean one of
many that Robert ended up becoming King
is because he was the popular choice
next question Keanu asks do you think if
Cersei was never part of Jaime's life he
would have been more honorable like Ned
Stark so you're saying you know like if
they hadn't have been so close and you
know just been so weird when they were
young I think he probably would have
been fairly normal he would have gone on
to Squire for someone then raised to
knighthood probably would have been
called back to Casterly Rock
so when Tywin died he would take over
Cersei would get married to a Targaryen
if they were still alive at the time I
mean there's no way to know how Robert's
rebellion would have gone down had
things been differently for Jaime
growing up actually I don't think it
would have been too much different
because Jamie and Tywin's actions didn't
figure so much into why the rebellion
started the Mad King probably still
would have roasted Brandon and Rickard
stark Rhaegar probably would have still
absconded with Liana
so he still would have gotten the civil
war but Jaime would have had a much more
typical place in it the war itself might
have gone a little quicker too because
Tywin still would have hated the Mad
King but he would have far fewer reasons
holding him back
from joining Robert side so I guess you
could say yeah you know Jamie might have
been a little bit more like Ned Stark
but he would have been way more boring
this version of Jaime is is way more
interesting next question Daniel asks
what is Marjorie's current situation
she's at a prison right yeah
currently I mean she's been released by
the faith but she's still awaiting trial
she and Laura still have to go on trial
just like Cersei the way the high
Sparrow explained it you because of
their confessions Marjorie and lorises
they'd be looked upon favorably shown
mercy as in mother's mercy there was a
lot of metaphors being thrown around
like he was basically implying that
because they confessed they would get
reduced sentences then go much lighter
on him the high Sparrow is really
gunning for Cersei next question Lana
asks do you think that Gendry could
become more relevant at some point I see
him as an underdog I can't help feeling
we should keep him in mind based on the
direction the show is going I don't
think that we have enough time to bring
him back into a relevant storyline I
feel like in the books like or I mean on
the show if he does come back it'll have
something more to do with arias
storyline and it feels like there's
really slim chances of that happening
the only reason to bring him back right
now in the Seven Kingdoms is is another
candidate to rule because of what Varys
interior are doing like it's a it's a
show telling us that that candidate the
new candidate is Daenerys they're mostly
concerned with Circe's fight with the
faith in King's Landing and what's going
on up in the north and in Daenerys like
slowly marshaling power in the East the
Dorne store line could get wrapped up in
like like another successor for the
throne like the Merciless storyline from
the books but it seems like they're not
doing that because it seems like she's
dead and with respect to arias storyline
I mean they could bring Gendry back in
the East but it seems like they're
trying to take away Arya safety net and
bringing Gendry back would completely
undercut that but he's not dead yet I
mean he's still rowing his way to King's
Landing thank you so much everyone for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do like I said you know
probably gonna do some more Robert's
rebellion stuff for my next bonus video
so be sure to subscribe to get that and
a new round of the giveaway will start
whenever I'd do that and that actually
reminds me congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner brian de Kowski
you win a $20 Amazon gift card just
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info a lot of
you guys have been requesting specific
bonus videos for
like certain characters and stuff some
of the videos I've already done so what
you should do is just scan through my
season 5 playlist I haven't changed the
place a little bit since season five
minutes so like every Game of Thrones
video that I post goes in that playlist
so just like scan down it and see if
there's a video that I've already posted
that you want to see once we get a
little closer to season 6 I'll probably
break off like a season 6 playlist
because a lot of the stuff that I'm
talking about now is more relevant to
season 6 than it is the season 5 just in
case you didn't see yesterday I posted a
big Jaime Lannister history video you
can click here to watch that and you can
click here to learn about some like
really big YouTube updates that are
happening and some stuff that's going on
with my channel thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you